july of 2014 has now come and gone and
were it not for a couple of standout
games it wouldn't have made much of a
mark on video game history nonetheless
we're grateful for the returns of
beloved games like the loss of us which
landed on the PlayStation 4 with
improved lighting a speedier frame rate
and the excellent left behind adventure
that had previously been available as a
downloadable add-on for the PlayStation
3 version we're also glad to have spent
more time again with the residents of
odd world in the new and tasty remix a
remake that was far more than just a
high-definition upgrade Dark Souls 2
kings bounty and child of light all
returned to the stage and commanded the
spotlight in one way or another but when
it comes to games with lasting presence
it was the walking dead that most amazed
us finding new ways to move and shock us
in clementines world tensions rise and
hopes Wayne and we continue to be
invested in her fate just as we look
forward to both the seasons conclusion
and next year's episodic continuation
Telltale's brutal entry was not our
choice for july's game of the month
however instead that honor goes to a
brand new game set in an
underappreciated universe we speak of
course about divinity original sin it
would be easy to point to the way
original sin recaptures the glory days
of role-playing games as the source of
its excellence after all you play it
from a top-down perspective and engage
with enemies using a party of four
adventurers each of whom perform skills
and spells associated with a class or
magical specialty presuming that
original sin is great because it's like
the games of old is to do the game a
disservice though it is great because
it's fresh and new delivering one
surprise after another and demanding
that you make good use of every tool
every spell and every weapon the command
system is one way in which original sin
proves its unique and
here the elements interact and erupt
fire turning oil into a pool of blazing
treacle and lightning causing every
puddle of water into an electrical
hazard every element is hazardous but
combined elements are downright deadly
both to you and the colorful array of
creatures and cultists you face every
battle requires that you proceed with
caution though you could say that about
all of divinity original sin each choice
you make even seemingly minor ones could
result in unforeseen consequences and
it's the natural systematic way in which
of those consequences play out that make
original sin stand out among other RPGs
that also boast multiple parts and moral
quandaries divinity original sin
provides a world of wonder and a fair
challenge using the trappings of the
classics weird or to tell a brand new
tale and to introduce brand new tactical
considerations it is sometimes funny and
sometimes grim sometimes tense and
sometimes easygoing but original sin is
always special and the runaway winner
for july's game in the month award